today we're giving a special shout out
to our favorite adult-friendly platform
fansly the best platform to connect
one-on-one with your favorite creators
in new and more intimate ways than ever
before
chat unlock exclusive content watch live
streams and connect your twitter or
twitch to see if creators you already
engage with are on fansly today what are
you waiting for check out fansley.com
that's
fansleyfansly.com for exclusive content
from your favorite creators
okay but how many different financial
accounts do you actually have
if you're tired of jumping from your
credit card account to your checking to
your investments just figuring out how
you're doing it's time to take back
control of your financial life with
rocket money start cancelling your
unused subscriptions and save money at
rocketmoney.com
trash tuesday that's rocketmoney.com
trash tuesday now a word from our
sponsor better help better help is
online therapy that offers video phone
and even live chat only therapy sessions
so you don't just see anyone on camera
if you don't have to and it's much more
affordable than in-person therapy and
you can be matched with a therapist in
under 48 hours
our listeners get 10 off their first
month at betterhelp.com
trash tuesday
that's betterhelp.help.com
trash tuesday hello slugs and sluggetts
it's me your favorite comedian
we have quite a show for you coming up
but before that let's get to business
okay i'm on family vacation
sick as hell
um don't worry about what's in my cup
it's my cup
you can see me i'll be refreshed and
ready this september early september you
can see me the 9th through 10th in at
the pittsburgh improv i'll then be
at the la jolla comedy store in
september i will also be at the tempe
improv you can then see me oh september
30th one night only at the caluso casino
baby
i will then in october the 7th through
8th i will be in
kansas city at the improv i'll be at the
irvine improv october 20th the san jose
improv november 11th through 12th i'll
be in michigan in december and in
florida at the end of december right
before christmas go to andyletterman.com
shows to find out also catch me on my
spotify audio show each monday 5 p.m uh
pst don't bore me where it's your turn
to not bore me you can find on the
spotify live app all right love you guys
you guys in less than a month i am going
to be in austin at cap city comedy club
september 16th and 17th then i'm going
to phoenix arizona
seattle and portland oh my god literally
all my favorite places you can get
tickets at
esteronice.com and this friday i'm
launching my solo podcast
it's called my pleasure and it's
available wherever you listen to
podcasts audio only
[Music]
i mean
the ketamine did not work and um i feel
like i um
i'm trying a new approach to um staying
centered
i'm trying to what do you call it like
um
um
b
b's grounding no butthole um oh the
sun's sunny [ __ ] b sunning
i don't know what the actual term i
don't is that the medical term i think
uh you're searching for a medical term
and you're coming no it's a jt and chad
um term i think it's be hole stunning
wait is it real i've been seeing this do
we need to be certain
is that really true i feel like yours is
dark enough
what do you mean
i you know um there's a lot of hair it
has oh that's true jules what color is
your butthole like black yeah mine's
pretty good
mine is i'm multiracial if you see my
[ __ ] apparently stella berry who
hopefully will have on the show sue and
she explains it really well with
scientific terms like haplogenes as to
why certain people have um purple
kitties as she calls it so um
um thank you for it's a gene it's a gene
it's a i think it's like a
mediterranean gene so i'm super
mediterranean just so you guys know
my [ __ ] actually
do you want to check mine
why wheels
you wouldn't make your niece do that
it's so funny is the filipino version of
you this is actually so this is like
you think esther would say no to seeing
my [ __ ]
i if you were a related maybe yeah
wait that's so funny that that's who you
choose i don't have anyone else in the
house what if you guys have opposite
color [ __ ] like your asshole's her
skin color and her you're like a yin
yang
these are the yin yang twins
you guys we have a very special guest
today i think the most face already
she she never wants to be anywhere we
ask her to be she doesn't want to be on
bad friends she doesn't want to be on
tiger belly she certainly doesn't want
to be on here but we're happy to have
her anyways she's my
little helper my little life helper
my niece and everyone knows her by um
bad friend rudy everyone jules aka rudy
can i know the background of why you got
rudy it was just random it's just you
two andrew just said that
i look like rudy from the giuliani
giuliani
yeah and so he named me that actually
i'm so happy that it didn't happen to me
i feel like that would have been me
we
but okay
you would be they would call you um
bannon danny devito oh yeah i want to be
bannon i love his clothes um i would
love to share a wardrobe his closet wait
you i always think of you as a child
but i feel like you might not be you
know that's how everyone talks to you
you guys know the exact term everyone
speaks to you only projecting are you a
child or not
i'm 20 so i i don't know if that's do
you feel like a child no what do you
feel like
mature
not like baby
but how long have you felt that way
adult like an adult
like i think when i came here to the us
she i would say you were kind of a baby
still when you first came here how old
were you when you came here seventeen
seventeen yeah you were sixteen did you
first time you just have an
unaccompanied minor past when you flew
over yeah oh my god they made you wear
that jewels the pink
you're a little too old for it right i
was like this is like creepy why are you
looking at me it's just like a bunch of
pilots looking at you like ew but she
had to travel 24 hours across the world
so i think
um that was the most adult thing you
could have done was just and i i and was
that exciting for you the first time i
was like hey you got to fly alone yeah
had you flown anywhere before had you
visited before
no
only at like the islands in the
philippines but not outside which is
only like 45 minutes if we were to like
hang out
what do you think we would do
like we just got started
like was just you yeah
she's horrified
let me just tell you you'd somehow end
up folding her thing i don't know how
that would happen you'd be cleaning up
donuts puke
would we like go out for milkshakes like
what do kids our age do
esther i can assure you that she has a
much more active adult life than all of
us really
last time i saw her she was going to the
harry styles concert yeah harry styles
yeah do you like harry styles i do now
wait so harry styles is cool yeah
hairstyles is cool
do you like enemy
yeah you know how biracial people like
feel like they don't fit in and either
race you're like that with age because
there's
nowhere
that's how i felt my whole life it's
like belonging everywhere but nowhere at
all yeah
that's how i feel about loud and quiet
what i'm like i'm a loud person but i
identify as quiet
okay but i want everyone else to be
quiet around me
wait isn't today um supposed to be a
college themed episode
i feel like annie and i showed up but
our two little babies didn't because i
dress like i'm in college every day that
is actually true this is like the least
college you've ever looked what that's
well
i because i was digging through my
closet i'm like how do i dress like
college and then i realized everything
was college and then somehow i ended up
in this i don't know but pajama bottoms
yeah yeah it's pajama bottoms it's
always but everyone's now just dressing
college do people still wear pajama
bottoms out in college i've never seen
anyone
wear
pajamas like
looking at us like that it's just wait
what about if they're living in the
dorms
maybe just in the dorms but not in class
pajama pants feel very midwest to me
like i feel like when i lived in the
midwest i saw them out in the real world
all the time and
now i think sweatpants like pants
replace them
but it used to be like you would wear
like patterned ugly ass bright pajama
bottoms slides with socks too
i almost wore that today mine i did
slides with berks
there was a lot of bikinis i remember my
friend and i would like be on the quad
in bikinis we thought it was funny
just when i thought we couldn't be more
different she hits me with that and i
remember the the school pastor who was
maybe the thing you bleeped out
who's this school she was this woman
pastor with she had purple hair she was
like put some clothes on girls and we
were like we're never gonna be lame like
her and now i'm like i feel like i would
probably put some clothes on girls no no
i know we would wait what were your like
dreams and aspirations before heading
out into college were you like what were
your expectations did you know for sure
what college you were gonna go to did
you commit you were talking to the wrong
two girls no i had big plans [ __ ] i had
big plans
because i mean high school was such a
horror show for you i imagined you had
maybe some no i liked it it was fun to
get just done by my teacher
are you kidding me how boring was your
high school
mine was really
fun and sparkly
it was fun i got jackson pollock's i
loved it um
no i wanted to be well i had taken a
year off and i'd done all this like
service work in other countries and
stuff not christian but
just
non-denominational service work there is
non-denominational service work yeah it
was just like this program i went on
where we did
i think i told you guys this we did like
the sea turtle thing that's where i grew
to hate sea turtles sea turtle vagina
specifically the [ __ ] juice because it
has a very pungent smell that i'll never
get rid of i i caught the eggs still on
your skin you can't get it off it feels
like yeah i'm like get off damn [ __ ]
juice um i think that was a shakespeare
macbeth yeah oh
she's like wrong girl theater major oh
we know exactly what she was doing i
would have loved to be lady macbeth but
i was witch three the [ __ ] witch i'm
surprised you weren't just the skull
they didn't just hold you up
wait jules was in theater
no don't that is good
that's good to be embarrassed good for
you
but wait can i give you some advice
though okay i was like you're too cool
to admit of theater dreams but then this
one just went with it and look at her
she's a movie star no i'm not but i was
witch three and i did make her the
[ __ ] witch and that was not scripted
and it really is that where you got your
hat maybe i wore purple eyeshadow it was
really cool that's your big [ __ ] move
i was wearing purple eyeshadow at birth
[ __ ]
but do you guys know jules was legit in
theater
what happened did you need an elective
or you wanted it um yeah i needed an
elective and then at the class i just
tried theater wait no no no let's be
honest
you said they're holding auditions and i
was like are you interested oh my god
you're such a stage mom
i didn't force her into it jules you
said they're holding auditions and then
i said are you interested in what did
you say i said maybe she said i want to
be a star did you dance and sing around
the room she's saying i sang you wait
you got in the play yeah but like not
the major roles i just i was just like
uh like a scrub
what was that esther was really trying
and chilling i've been a tree in a play
before so this is
uh i'm sorry you're a shrub a tree the
shortest tree of all time an oak tree
yesterday there was a tree in ballet
like yeah no i never got big rolls
that's why i'm messed up as an adult i
got um i was the there's esther
i was that actually kind of looks like
you it's like if you two had a baby um i
was the usher ones
oh that's a very important rule no no no
no no they didn't even let me on the
stage to be they cast me as the usher
wait you can't get cast as though no no
they did when they were like you're not
gonna be in this play young lady we
thank you for auditioning we're going to
make you the [ __ ] usher
we know you're available on these dates
so we're going to actually put you to
work for free oh my god to look at the
cast list and then see usher i think it
was even on the second column it was
like me and my brother were the only
ones but it was for annie and i went in
for the audition and i of course don't
want to sing you know how embarrassed
i'm to sing right yeah but i practice i
had a little cassette annie and i
practice and i practice but with no help
you know just alone in my room thinking
that whatever confidence i built in the
room would stay in front of a room full
of people staring at me
so then i went right back to being like
way more embarrassed than before i'd
been embarrassed and i sang and um
i think it was uh the other one tomorrow
that i sang it's hard like it's a hard
not like it could have done like that
but annie this one you really have to
belt out it's a heart this is these are
hard songs
this is a hard one they go why do you
think you should get it and i go because
i'm annie no one laughed
turns out they thought i was a black r b
singer because i became an usher
i think your song choice was really good
it was emotional did you know what the
play was ahead of time before you
auditioned no okay but what what did it
take so you could pick anything you
could pick any song it was just
something rotten at that oh right right
and then it's called something rotten
yeah and then
um what was your audition song
it was the lumineers
dead sea dead c yeah that's a super
emotional song
i think that's why you got it it was
very like uh you chose like a song that
like really digs deep okay you are
really transforming in front of my eyes
into like an embarrassing stage
look at her we understand why she's
doing this most of her life because
you're so happy and i know i am it's
like so sweet and she's just like so
crazy she hates all of it she couldn't
yeah she didn't get it yeah like if my
when my mom talks about my dancing it's
like the worst thing that could ever
she's oh my god can we call her and have
her do it right now no because
realistically she'll it'll not be nice
oh my god you're just making up that
your mom said nice things about you no
sometimes she would be positive about it
but yeah no
jules do you think it was a mistake that
we um sent you to um a christian school
no because even if i had like bible
classes and like had to go to like
church every wednesday i never
really like cared about it but i
remember having to listen to you like
like learn the bible yeah like i have to
like memorize all the verses and like
interpret it and then
yeah it was stupid but i don't really
care
inter predator is a very cute way to say
interpreted
she's got your cute little
cuter but slightly cute oh no don't get
jealous i know my accent she's gonna
steal uh brad pitt from amitri or
whatever um excuse me did you not see my
text to you guys yes but do you know
that we actually did that right
yes okay one week we talked about emrata
one week we did the next week we talked
about brad pitt and now they're together
so there are there's rumors that brad
pitt and emratta are she doesn't want us
again
i don't want to get sued no i'm just
kidding but um
i was actually rooting for and i think
carlos and i and our other friends
talked about this
emratta and pete davidson that seemed
like it made the most sense no no no why
pete's done yeah pete's done he's just
all over he's like he's all [ __ ] up
he's like 24. it's disgusting wait
should kalila date pete davidson maybe
oh my god that's so funny
we both have colitis it will not work
you need dual bathroom do you know how
the second the bathroom's like yeah we
need to have two toilets side by side
someone i think it was um um giannis
papa who was like i think he should try
for michelle obama next
i was like well at this rate that sort
of makes sense
oh jules what do you think of
uh
us are we like creepy old people to you
no i think you're
cool
really the fact that we have to ask this
i ask her every day by the way like am i
still cool am i still and she says yes
and she's like yeah you're still okay
yeah
like there's some like same people your
age is like really chooky and just not
cool and just lame
is she talking about me
no i know i'm cool baby
i'm not esther going am i cool
today's podcast is brought to you by
fansley an innovative adult-friendly
platform allowing you to connect
intimately with content creators
think tiktok but for spicy content and
exclusive
access assess access to your favs follow
subscribe message creators to chat
one-on-one unlock pay-per-views you
definitely won't see anywhere else and
discover new favorites on fansley's for
you page where new creators are
suggested based on the ones you already
love and engage with you can even sign
up through twitter or twitch to see if
the creators you follow are also on
fansly
and if you're thinking of becoming a
creator fansly is the best for fan
engagement content sales and growing a
dedicated audience you can post safe for
work picks by day spice it up at night
or both with tons of optional features
like sub tiers paid messaging and more
fansly is not just for adult content you
can get an interactive outlet for
creative and exclusive posts from your
favorite artists and i personally love
places like fansley because
i want to be able to support adult
creators
because that's just the more ethical
route to take what are you guys waiting
for sign up today at fansley.com that's
fansleyfansly.com for exclusive content
from your favorite creators
you guys if you keep saying that you
need to make a budget but you never do
it if somehow you keep missing credit
card payments or if you're afraid to
look at your bank statement i know that
feeling so well then it's time that you
take back control of your financial life
meet rocket money which was formerly
true bill our favorite financial app
so why did true bill change its name to
rocket money okay we'll tell you what we
heard
true now backed by rocket companies has
grown from a bill management app into a
full-on personal finance empowerment
tool that helps over 3.4
million people with budgeting lowering
bills canceling subscriptions and more
saving each of their members on average
700 a year now
money management and all that stuff is
not taught to us it's something you have
to really seek out
and with all that growth comes the next
evolution in true bill's story a new
name
bottom line rocket money is everything
that we've always loved about trubell
but with a fresh look and feel
so you guys can start cancelling your
unused subscriptions and save money at
rocketmoney.com
tuesday that's rocketmoney.com
trash tuesday or download the app from
the apple store or the google play store
[Music]
i did realize it's funny because
okay so bonnie mcfarlane who was on the
show who's a friend of mine she's she's
older than me but her daughter is
14. i just turned 14 and since her she
was three i've been trying to get like
her approval and then probably bonnie
was like since she was three well
because she's literally the meanest
child i've ever met in my life she's so
funny and mean she was raised by south
park
and by oh sorry i mean family guy so she
has like
punchlines and she hurts you
but uh and then like i think when she
was around 10 bonnie was like why do you
want the approval of my daughter i was
like oh i guess that's a good point
and then i gave up thinking
this will get her i'll give up it hasn't
worked actually you're right though i i
all good
i mean now that i know i'm cool it's
easier to give up but
wait rudy i have a question yeah you
called bad friends cringe
getting the tattoo would be crazy like
the word bad friend what about trash
tuesday
you're getting tattooed we're gonna fire
people who get tattooed no just a bad
friend's tattoo what the oh because you
guys all wanted to get them yeah it's
slain yes it is good for you jules
it is lame yeah yeah are you getting it
carlos are you getting it pete
no they wanted her to get one and she
and andrew was just kind of upset
because she kept calling bad friends
cringe
it's so good
do you think he's upset because that
rhymes with ginge
[Laughter]
oh gosh um jules one of the topics that
we've held off talking about um
until we had you was army hammer and
cannibalism
yeah
and i want you to tell the girls just
your general thoughts on cannibalism
okay where you stand on it
i mean i'm not
like i don't support it but like if it's
like in like a sexual way and the both
partners consent and that it's just like
role play i guess it's fine but are you
eating flesh of another person it's like
are you swallowing it's imaginative
good girl that's a good gen z answer i
mean i was asking about
this but oh
um
but just generally
what happened we just
are any of you even remotely curious as
to what
any type of human meat would taste
no not at all i told you the way i'll
eat it i'll eat it if someone died and
they donated their exact meat to me
they'd have to like sanji i want danny
letterman to eat me i'll go okay i want
to
talk more about this though so you
are
so
wise
that you're viewing it as a sexual
fantasy right off the gate yeah
because is it isn't it sexual to him and
the other girl
i think the
yes i mean in theory you can be anything
you want if both parties agree yeah
right but if both party agrees that it's
imaginary and the other person is
actually chewing meat off of your body
he really wants to like eat her yeah
like then there's there's a difference
between someone actually like to eat
eating your baby toe
okay then maybe no
it's just if you're if your toe would
grow back
i'm down you know what i mean but you're
just gonna give your [ __ ] toe to some
schmuck actor i want would any of us i'm
just trying to get myself into character
here like could i need to
get turned on by a role play where
there's cannibalism involved like would
i want a guy to eat me what if it's two
girls
i would i feel like i would eat girls
it has to be good for you can i ask the
boys a question
now cannibalism i just want you to know
where my add brain went cannibalism
triggered the word cantaloupe
now there was a kid in my high school
who said he [ __ ] a cantaloupe
he put a carved a hole in infected
carlos have you [ __ ] a candle i feel
like of all you'd be the perfect canada
cantaloupe [ __ ] candidate
would you do you believe a pillow before
and how
like rubbing my dick against it like
that's not like inserting it that's more
of like
you didn't like get duct tape involved i
actually thought it'd be a really good
only fans if i was like
if i [ __ ] pillows i was like oh i
wonder if i could make a lot of money oh
i'm okay oh i feel like you could though
honestly i don't know what you mean by
really good
but it would be really something well
you just gave it a free commercial good
job well to that i want to say
um i've never had a penis before if you
can believe that
but the shoulders are making it really
tough
but
i
the jawline feathers does not seem like
it would feel remotely pleasurable
against my imaginary people do you stick
them to your afternoon do you stick it
do you stick them do tar and feather
your penis
no it's more but like the friction feels
soft against my dick to the pillow
this is current this is not a while ago
this is like last night yeah oh yeah i
will definitely do it not like last
night but like well i haven't
used it you guys masturbate without toys
right i don't need to bother you with
this no it would bother her
oh my god she's a grown-up you're right
she's a grown-up
but
i had a friend who was like you have to
masturbate only with your hand with your
knuckle and you have to lay on your
stomach
and do it and i remember doing that for
like a month and then i was like i'm
just gonna get more batteries like is
this really i can't drive to rite aid
also if you don't have very long arms
and imagine you having to really stretch
but you're not going like you're not
fisting inside it's just on the
clip i know but some people you you have
long arms you and i have long arms some
people are t-rexes they can't get down
there that in that way she's trying to
yeah
um
carlos i have a suggestion for your only
fans
i think that you should get pillow
sponsors and you should try out
different brands and then really rank
them and say hey guys this week i'm
using a target pillow
and um next week i'm doing brooklyn or
something i do have so grossed out by
this whole thing if carlos is the one to
come out of this show with an only fans
we've all failed i feel like we've no i
feel like we have to get a percentage of
it though
i like where you're headed okay and then
i'm fine with it
i'll hook you up annie trash tuesday not
like with a he's like oh who can put the
subscription i don't want to see it no
you could be like tier three or
something we need to send you a note
every month
oh my god you're like guys i'm dm'ing
this winky face
get ready for your dms would you guys
ever want to eat a girl in a sexual
fantasy is that like the ultimate
domination or something i think that's
what it is the ultimate domination and
all quiet
it's like i'm married i can't talk about
it it's always quiet the answer is no
the answer is no
well i wonder like i've i've had guys
that are like
i've never had a guy that's like psyched
when i'm on my period to have sex but i
know there are guys out there that
probably really like it maybe they like
the metal blood taste
i'm into it the heme the female
yeah
does it get in your wings you actually
have red wings because it gets in your
winged hair
i don't think i would want to
participate in a role-playing fantasy
where the person is eating me i don't
i'm like that's too you're you're taking
it does feel like my body it's just like
cheesy when someone's like yummy i don't
like that when people are like um well
delicious yummy i'm like what about this
guys
um
what about if brad pitt finally calls
and says hey i
you gotta do whatever the [ __ ] he asked
okay that's what i'm saying right that's
not our problem that's yours
what part of my body should go first
well first of all
okay
she said your nose is going to be a
[ __ ] hole in my oh my god then she
just has the whole face
have you seen the guy what's the guy the
uh what's his name i feel like carlos
knows the guy that cut his nose off and
slit his tongue and has all the tattoos
black something project something black
project
he cut his nose off intentionally yeah
he just made himself a freak like he
just made himself so you think my nose
should go but i don't like the look of
no nose not like a finger i was thinking
like yeah more something where we're not
seeing it oh my god you're gonna act
like a toe isn't a big problem after
what you put us through when you broke
your toe i was thinking like biting you
know if if a guy's gonna eat you you
want to like bite out your thigh yeah
like a chunk of my thigh i think show
the nose show the nose this is what you
want you want her nose to look like that
the lips being gone is gross but also
kind of amazing did he um um
the lip thing did he sew half of his
mouth i don't know or is that just how
he's smiling i don't know but he looked
pretty normal before i kind of i think
this body modification is is cool do you
think do you think my mom is so freaked
out since i started weed that i'm like
this crazy drug addict i should go home
and take this guy and be like this is my
new husband
[Laughter]
look he cut his fingers off to have
claws i just don't know why you would
[ __ ] with your ability to like do things
especially well he you clearly he's
never gonna cut his own thumb off
because you need opposable thumbs to get
most things done especially to hold that
phone like that go back to the last
picture
you know he wasn't going to choose his
thumbs
yeah that's interesting yeah
maybe the other fingers could just go
well which one would we offer to the
beginning of the end of esther
i want to use esther wait i was thinking
about you getting your boob job out yeah
i really want to commend you that is
like so to change your mind on something
that's such a big deal is huge only two
years actually under two years i like
that it's like when people get divorced
and you're like you know i'm kind of
[ __ ] proud of you dude like you know
even better i had a friend who got a
divorce six months after her honestly
the most expensive wedding i had ever
seen in my life
dude slipped up
he cheated she was like [ __ ] this [ __ ]
everything goodbye was it mario lopez
remember when mario lopez and ali
laundry were married for like one day no
yeah and then the guy the people from
one tree hill did the same thing
it's like these guys get caught cheating
like the day after the wedding it's so
crazy
it's like what do you [ __ ] get made
at the
honeymoon
sally it's like laundry landry he
cheated on her at his bachelor party
that's how she found out
she was like the pop dorito girl
remember
oh i want to ask you guys this question
about tick-tock do you know how like
there is a whole section of tick-tock
that outs cheating man or cheating
spouses
where they're like hey if um
if your man was at a bachelor party in
vegas this weekend and his name's steve
and he had so and so friends um just so
you know like he [ __ ] my homegirl
letty you know what i mean like they're
ready i saw one that was like
i almost do edit it because it was so
funny how degrading he was being to the
bride and i wanted to pretend it was me
he was like she was pathetic she was
trying to [ __ ] all my friends
i think i saw that one it was so funny
but what do we think of that
is there just a
i don't know it's like the chris hansen
but like the marriage version well it's
because you don't know what they're
they've agreed to yeah we also don't
know what she's doing on her bachelor
you know what i mean it's like
it's i think they're funny tick tocks
but
who's really gonna
like see that and be like wait a second
i think that was okay let's let's let's
paint the picture let's uh
annie you and todd are engaged
right
um you're not doing a dual bachelor
bachelorette party like carmen elektra
and dave navarro i can't imagine that
that we're separated okay
and so
exactly he's without me no
and so um
someone on tick tock is like hey if your
dude was and where would todd be
in jersey oh vegas come on we're both in
vegas we're having dual bachelor parties
but we are going to end up in the same
room at the end of the night probably
right so but if you see a tic tac hey
you know if your boyfriend's name is
todd and he was at the
you know at um the circle bar at
cosmopolitan blah blah blah um just so
you know like my friend gave him a
[ __ ] in the bathroom like how would
you as a woman like how would you
take that information
is it like over is it
i just don't
i can't even imagine this happening yeah
me neither by the way as i was saying it
i was like this is like i could imagine
me sending like i've looked at his vms
it's there's nothing happening it's so
boring it's like there's no excitement
in that realm like he i'm so in such a
secure relationship it's i know that
there's going to be guys at home that
are like that's what they cheat
but
yeah i know why i went into my tony
that's what they cheat um i feel like
mine would be like we saw your fiance
dave he was
begging someone to hook up with his wife
he was like playing poke i mean it would
just be
i mean i literally showed up at his
bachelor party and he was high in his
room watching the news our boyfriends
are very into gambling too like they
like to play poker and stuff so they
would be using the time to like make
money or try to win a game yeah wait he
he's already had a bachelor party
yeah
this was back when he thought we were
actually going to have a wedding and get
married so how long and then you started
clovid so you didn't have to
when you came up with this guy and then
i get
wait how long ago did he have his
bachelor party like three or four years
ago
i have a question what how long have you
been together with your
with dave
that's exactly how dave feels doing uh
10 years do you still do you get like an
ick from him or like
just talking about this um
okay so
yes i actually do get an ick factor
but
uh i also think that
i'm not like basically i was literally
just at a party where my friend and dave
were arguing because she like is very
sensitive to the ick yeah and dave was
like the ick is made up and it's
[ __ ] and it's just a way for you
guys to humiliate us
but i do get the egg explain the egg
the ick
the ick is this it's like when you know
when you're first meeting a guy
and he does something so mundane so
silly like he plugs his nose when he
jumps in the pool and it's like an
irreversible i will never
ever
date you feeling like it's wrong they're
friends on themselves with like a
movement yeah whitney famously talks
about this how like a guy tripped on a
first date and she was like
no but it's here's the thing about the
ick though i think if you get the ich 10
years in or years into the relationship
you're not out it's just an
acknowledgement of i hate
that little thing he did but i'm
sticking it out like i'm here i think
the ick has like
a zone of time where it could affect you
and i think like if you get an ick in
the first three months or maybe even the
first month like then you'll be like
because they're still forming your
feelings yeah right but 10 years in i
definitely get it i get the ick and i'm
just like whatever
you just live with it i think my ick for
when i was with bobby was when like
years years ago
there aren't
so many
believe it or not it wasn't the the the
fecal matter in the car it wasn't any of
that
it was
it was him
dipping one day like i'm such a orally
like fixated person and i hate i saw him
spitting in a spittoon or a water bottle
and immediately like my body like
recoiled it was so gross to me but we
were it had already been together six
years in so like he knew after that to
always like hide the dipping yeah for me
because that was just the one like he
smokes you know i don't care if he
doesn't brush his teeth whatever but the
dipping something about that i was like
oh
i can't think of ics with todd
bottomless functions don't give me the
ick like like same like it's not
like i don't want to like out well let's
just say if i was dating someone and
they had to like rush home to have
diarrhea like right that doesn't give me
the eggs oh my god i would have no i've
never had i would've had the ick my
whole life everybody i've ever had is an
emergency you guys i had diarrhea on a
hike yesterday and i [ __ ] on the trail
doesn't that feel so good uh it was
honestly once you know you're not like
gonna get did were you covered are
people covering you yeah but also i
don't have um poopoo shy out in the
wilderness it's like if you cross me i'm
like guys that's when you'll look the
most native american is like if you're
like you're like you just look and you
see this long hair and this woman just
like in the woods but i pick my [ __ ] up
with a doggy bag and i carry it down how
did she like was it heavy
diarrhea i pick up what i can annie i i
dust off i put the soil in to kind of
make it into a batter or like a more
solid
and then i pick it up
you're not gonna take this
you're not gonna [ __ ] pit she dug a
pit to put her [ __ ] in do you understand
exactly thank you
she's on ketamine therapy she's getting
better are you serious brad how did you
wipe
oh without my water bottle i used all my
water
squirt bottle
the day she brought a bidet with her
yeah mechanical watch the day for the
day
wow
i've never [ __ ] in the wilderness
believe it or not um i don't know have
you been in the wilderness
that's really i'm like impressed i'm
inspired
because i've always been like what if
there is a do do emergency right it
feels great to squat down it's how it's
supposed to go
when the [ __ ] you can feel the [ __ ] like
just touch the ground and it makes your
pile yeah and sometimes it kisses just
ever so slightly the other piece coming
down right it's like a stalactite and a
stalagmite
your ass belongs i have a new challenge
for myself i want to like
go on hikes with hopes of having to [ __ ]
and like get over this set yourself up
for success drink a lot of coffee right
before more than you usually would right
go get a kale shake
um and all your trigger foods right and
then just go on your little anti-sadness
walk and i hope you [ __ ] not on soil but
uncle my god for you on that walk to
take a [ __ ] oh my god humility
guys it's a funny walk it's a funny
place she walks
what if you got a
oh god
wow what if like a producer was driving
by and like wow that's definitely gonna
happen that's what we were looking for
jules have you had have you felt an ick
for a boy
um
like a couple of times just like how
they walk how they talk
and then like
like if they talk and then like does it
their saliva goes out
the corners yeah oh corners are rough
yeah there's
oh it's something in their teeth yeah
but you don't tell them how you're not a
teller no
you wouldn't hook a homie up be like hey
dude
no i just don't talk to them after
wait okay one time in high school when i
really really had a crush on um
basically my big high school crush we
all know who he is i drive by his house
whatever i crushed on him for years
before we ever met and so when we
finally did meet and we were like
hanging out i literally went to the mall
and sat down with the one of the most
popular girls that i knew and i was like
let's talk i was like i want to know
everything about how i can get this guy
to like me and she was giving me all
these tips and one tip she gave me which
i didn't use because i thought it was
way too mean but she said
to tell him that he has something in his
teeth so that i could like gain
dominance and power over him
so where has this where's this girl now
she's
uh i don't want to say is she doing well
she's fine i think she's good you got to
tell us no i don't know i think she's
like working in dog rescues and stuff i
don't want to like she's dominating dogs
yeah no but no i'm just curious like if
she ended up being like
call her daddy
did she do it or not no is she married i
don't know
i don't want to like
talk
but it was she gave me like good advice
like that i think she also said she also
i don't know never mind come on
she like taught me i was like okay and
what about like having sex and she was
like you just do what feels good for you
oh god why did no one tell me that i
know
oh my god i know it was like i'm like
i'm thinking back i'm like i can't
believe i got all this really good
advice from this pretty girl in high
school let's just forfeit our jobs and
give her our job that girl deserves this
problem i know she was like the original
caller daddy are you [ __ ] kidding me
where the [ __ ] were we what was told to
us
nobody told me anything they just said
go for it do what they want
she was very like her parents i remember
they had like liquid latex in their
closet like they were very like
it was this
family
jules what would you say like when you
were growing up um in the philippines
like what kind of like sex ed did you
get
um nothing really because
my mom and dad
didn't really want to talk about it even
though they were like really open to
their like sex life they would talk
about their sex life yeah but they would
they wouldn't tell me anything like
figure it out kid yeah it's so it was
only you and i think a window that
really told me about stuff did we come
on too strong though
strong but i liked it
yeah okay
yeah they like sat you down they tied
you up they're like you're gonna listen
to us it's it basically it was basically
pulled out a chart
this is a clutch what did you even tell
her just curious it's basically like
you're gonna [ __ ] and here's how it's
gonna go down um you're gonna take care
of yourself you're always going to
prioritize safety you're going to
prioritize consent and you're going to
prioritize your pleasure
that's it i was robbed of a childhood
but that's because annie you and i had
such a shitty childhood i was so afraid
for her to have such negative
experiences so i was like have fun but
you know
safety first and all that stuff did that
help you yeah i was more confident with
like expressing and like doing stuff
because of her
wow
i do think having like an aunt or
older sister because i have to say one
of the big reasons why i never tried
drugs
is because not not hearing it from my
parents but hearing it from my sister
who was eight years older so she was
like cool you know
and her just basically scaring me off of
drugs like that really helped me so i
think like having
that kind of figure does
how what's your guys's age gap huge oh
um
she
20 years
no no no no almost 20 years like 18 yeah
18 years something like that
that was a good math i literally think
that you guys are like sisters it's so
weird
yeah but i think there will come a point
where you're going to look at me and be
like all right she's starting to feel
really old maybe when you're like 60.
that's how i feel about todd
yeah maybe
um
oh it's cute though
but but maybe i'm not an actualized
adult and i'm in some form of arrested
development and i mean the way you're
sitting is
you guys i by the way i'm wearing my
unlv shirt that says swimming and diving
i had to red shirt my freshman year and
i didn't end up getting to swim really
for unlv but i got hurt
um i had to i could not compete i i got
a full scholarship and a full ride there
dorms were paid for everything was paid
for and then
i had to uh
yeah i couldn't compete my freshman year
because they said i i was missing like
an ncaa credit that i was from the
philippines or something like that it
was really depressing but here it is
repping unlv i tried to find uh
i think from the college of santa fe but
i couldn't find it and it's been out of
business for so long that
it doesn't exist online but you know
what does exist online
mclemore saying that he learned how to
rap at the college of santa fe so if you
like mclemore you're welcome if you
don't like macklemore sorry
my college did that
i had i found one shirt from college
today and i almost wore it
but it's offensive it's the logo is the
chief
which has like since been discontinued
oh that would go for a lot of money on
ebay ugh it's so stupid like
i remember the year it was being
discontinued was our first year there
and everyone was like we gotta buy it up
before it's gone i'm like this is like a
scam like to make money it's so stupid
um
i know i've said this before but unlv
was my first choice right because of the
dance because of their jazz dance
program but my parents jazz dance
program that is wild
we were so different i i went to like a
big ten i feel like i'm the only one
here who had the real like classic big
ten college campus cornfield experience
so you were jazz wait jazz dance
no that's what i wanted i was getting
[ __ ] on my pants
during high school and you were planning
i was wearing jazz pants
we denied her all the schools she got
accepted to unfortunately i mean she got
accepted to like uc davis and these like
really um weren't schools but and but we
were like guess what you're staying
close
yeah
i'm still fine with it i just i just
want a party like a college party yes it
is that was fun yes but you know here's
the thing jules what was really [ __ ]
up for you was your senior year of going
of of high school in the united states
was a coveteer yeah and so it's like you
spent it with what me and bobby at home
fostering dogs like that's depressing so
it's like but there's you're turning 21
in november you can make up for all that
lost time yeah and um
so you know
you have all the time in the world to go
ape [ __ ] college party is fun it is it
is fun
they are yeah you have to have that
experience now what do you want to do
with um for your 21st birthday
i just want to do the karaoke thing
what was your first choice though
um las vegas
well
maybe we can throw her at 20 all i want
to do is go to vegas
good girl with a 21 year old girl i'll
go oh my god still be in the room
watching the news it's so weird that you
and dave have that in common on vacation
you just like to watch the news
now a word from our sponsor betterhelp
so
how well would you take care of your car
if you had to keep the same one for your
entire life okay
you know don't go based off what i've
done
you really do what's best for you but
honestly that is how our brain works
and so why shouldn't we also treat our
brain that way like let's take care of
it that is something that i do i may not
take care of my car i definitely put
good effort and focus into taking care
of my brain and there are plenty of ways
to support a healthy brain like learning
a new language or taking a power nap but
there's also better help online therapy
and i have to say for me without therapy
i would not function actually i would
never be able to accomplish and do the
things that i'm able to do without
getting help for my mental health better
help is online therapy that offers video
phone and even live chat only therapy
sessions so you don't just see anyone on
camera if you don't have to and it's
much more affordable than in-person
therapy and you can be matched with a
therapist in under 48 hours
our listeners get 10 off their first
month at betterhelp.com
trash tuesday
that's betterhelphelp.com
trash tuesday
i have a question for you guys um i saw
on um
tick tock obviously
um
this girl asking people like did you
grow up with a nakey mom or a non-nakey
mom
like did your mom get naked around you
oh here it is what did she say
did you all grow up with a naked mom and
i don't mean this in a sexual way like a
naked mom or a not naked mom here's what
i mean by this like i have good friends
who like you know you saw their mom
naked right now
they didn't see her getting dressed they
didn't see her getting ready for a
shower like going to the bathroom
nothing not the case with my mom i
facetimed her yesterday and she
literally answered the facetime start
naked getting ready to hop in the tub is
she whitney's daughter
naked mom or not naked mom i only know
of naked mom i did that once with my dad
it was so embarrassing
i like lit like he saw my boob for a
second i was like dad it was so bad i
was like he was like oh
i just forgot it wasn't my boyfriend you
know what i mean so your parents did
they ever get naked or naked all the
time yeah
not like nudist colony naked but like my
dad i would see excellent no one locks
doors or really barely closes them in my
family so i've seen my dad like peeing a
million times i i used to have a joke i
was like it's not christmas and so i've
seen my dad's dick he thinks it's
hilarious
like one time he came actually this was
the best so they have this like
stairwell that goes up i don't know what
you call it but like you you look down
you can you're on like the middle of the
stairs and you look down and there's the
the front door so like my dad was on the
stairwell and i was like coming up
coming in and he was like annie you're
here and he was wearing a nightgown with
no underwear oh my god dad i got like a
i was looking at it was like bird's eye
dick coming at me that's the ultimate um
ick for me is just dudes who's just
teaching oh god yes t-shirts only well
in burning man which i really wish i was
going to i'm going to go next year don't
think zoom in
back up carlos we can read it from there
who is this cutie it's so cute
should we keep going yeah just keep
going and then we'll get to this in a
bit so okay so um
ready man
burning man has a thing that's called oh
my friend just told me that but it's
something it's like where guys winnie
the pooh they do no pants
are you serious yeah i know it's like
ugh is that your worst case scenario
what burning man is
yes thank you because i have no idea
what it is but if i found out it was
that i'd be like i know there's like
naked people and drugs this burning
man's not for you basically this it's
like guys make sure you put your pants
on before your shirt every time because
if the shirt comes on first there's a
[ __ ] problem yeah i have a little
like my way out the door yeah
like it's such a baby it's a dangle
situation it's like it just accentuates
the dangle i don't want more dangle is
that what is there more what is it for
you if it's hard though honestly it's
not as bad
it if the shirt's on it's hard are you
talking about your dad
i've never seen my dad hard i will say
that okay
but to give you guys so nobody thinks i
was molested by my father i've never
seen him hard wait so annie so this
question but my mom's naked all the time
so this woman's asking if you had a
naked mom so you had a both naked yes
but my dad wasn't like naked on purpose
my family was an underwear family like
answer the door in your underwear there
were skid marks my mom had some real
skinny underwear but um
and also
they oh my god so much alike spread
their legs around a dog um
but
my mom like yeah she was always naked
she always also my mom played
racquetball i just was realizing how
traumatizing was to see my mom with
welts all over her thighs all the time
from racquetball yeah she always just
had giant bruises all over herself
what if my mom was in a bsm and that's
what she was doing on tuesday night
i know i saw her blind she was like
yeah my mom had like short hair and she
wore the goggles my mom's such a dude my
parents couldn't have been more
different my dad was very very um
proper super proper like he would fix
the collar on my shirt proper
um but then my mom was naked all the
[ __ ] time with a big bush and her
perfect [ __ ] body the worst part for
me was that i had a mother who was a
specimen so it's like i grow i grew up
watching this woman's abs just get more
chiseled and chiseled and then her
always like counting her calories she
would actually have a spreadsheet of all
the things that she would eat
um all her slim fast
products and so she was also a
bodybuilder so she spent a lot of hours
every day at baseline gym and i would
watch her compete
as a bodybuilder and as one of those you
know aerobics um oh my god
and so
that had its own um disadvantages why
spray 10 triggering for you did your mom
tan up naturally she's already tanned
she doesn't need
any like any she didn't add the oil or
anything though you know yeah they're
all shiny they get all shiny and yes
they did um so that was a little bit
more like i think that had its
you know
um psychological ramifications for a
young child and not so much the nudity
but the perfection that she always was
but do you think like okay so you're
very active too and it's less eating
disorder then i've
i'm i mean i actually don't know it's
super eating disorder but do you think
if there's like a but if there's like a
goal right is it less eating disorder
because she's counting her calories so
that she can compete is that less eating
disorder you know you're not you're just
absorbing what you're seeing you don't
know you're not thinking about it that
way not to diagnose my own mother but i
do look at her as someone who is
regimented but also like
obsessive-compulsive and a lot of that
has to do with her weight for instance
like yesterday like if i didn't go on
that hike with her and i knew that she
didn't get her workout in that day that
she would be in a negative mood for the
rest of the day wait is that why you
should your mom's like you're overweight
take a [ __ ] on the oh my god
on saturday i went home crying
as jules because we all went bowling as
a family and she asked me three
questions back to back and i just left
and i cried the whole way home
she asked me um
um
she asked me why are you eating more
sweet potatoes than you are your
proteins first question second question
is um how is your shoulder feeling and i
knew what the third question is you mean
to say you haven't worked out in three
weeks of your
shoulders savage and so i just took my
stuff and she's and then she later
explained she's like no i just know that
you probably don't feel good because you
haven't been working out and i'm worried
about your psychological state but
really it's like those three questions
back-to-back i was like i gotta get out
of here i was like thanks mom i'm fine
why is it interesting why is interesting
too what she goes why are you doing that
it's an interesting way to like point it
out yeah just curious i was just curious
why why you would be doing that
[Music]
i eat them with chocolate
oh that's cute
that's like a good actually no that's
good for the audience to know esther uh
that's good for the audience there's a
skinny coach
jules did you have um um
maybe i might know the answer i'm gonna
get the [ __ ] out of this good work
carlos that was a dare
i said i dare you to give her the rotten
one and see what happens do you have
naked mom and dad growing up um just mom
like i'd i would see like all like her
vagina and it's everyday
like say it that way if she was like
force them on you right yeah and like
she would let a smell like
her
like she would go her hands would go in
her vagina and then she would just
i feel like
that's the pets
that's crazy
that's why
because she thinks it's funny so
and that's why she came to america
that's your sister that's my sister
[Laughter]
you know you wonder why i wanted to see
my [ __ ] earlier it runs about very
normal honestly well we showered
together no i don't shower with jewels
but like growing up like as friends
or my family i could shower with my mom
i can shower with my sister
showering as a communal activity is very
common
and i wanted to ask you guys is it for
you
or not with your friends but i know with
family right good family yeah
yeah so showering with family is not
unheard of and it's not a weird thing i
shouted with more friends and family i
think
but is it for sports like oh at camp
we just had one big shower but as an
adult now do you still shower with
friends yeah i'll shower with a friend i
will yeah thank you i will it's like
funny my friend terry and i will throw
pop in a shower she's always yeah my
friend tara will just be like anna
she'll just be holding a diva cup like
in a tub when i call her
no but i want to ask you like if you're
sharing a hotel room with a friend of
yours
of course right of course
really yes sir no well i also don't i
haven't i don't take showers i take
baths but
i just i would only want to shower she
also travels with john campanelli so if
he climbed into a bath i think that
would be a problem that would actually
be so much fun
i would love to bathe with my guy
friends
carlos jump into the least sexual bath
yes that would be so fun i would do a
bathing suit bath with esther yeah
carlos yeah
no it's balls and tits out or no no
what are we at the [ __ ] pool
what are we just not pool the point is
all right i would do a nude one then
i would do a nude one but only with
everyone here
thank you i would do that
no
no i don't shower with my guy friends i
shower with my girlfriends you just
don't have any girlfriends that are
willing to do things with you that's
true
no they got naked in the pool in front
of me recently i didn't participate but
why not
too insecure i naked in the pool at a
party is like that's never going to
happen can i tell you that's when you've
gotten waxed
everyone's body is amazing in the pool
because it's like there's no gravity so
it actually kind of like sits up your
tits sit up everything sits up but how
do you get in the pool without revealing
your naked bodies hide the bush do that
you know what makes your body hot
not being insecure exactly
it really is i thought you were going to
say not being able to see it
close your eyes no no seriously it's the
hesitation makes your body think about
the guy like the the one it can come the
biggest sick i've ever gotten from a guy
is when i
we
both had sex we've already had sex but
then like i turned around and he was
like oh no and he like hide he hid his
soft [ __ ] oh i hate when guys hide their
soft [ __ ] oh no like it's over we're
never gonna do this again
that was like one of the like most
memorable icks i've had i'm like ah why
did he do that so why did you hold
yourself [ __ ]
with kalila
and end things
tragically
um
what are we looking at here um this was
the unlv um
brochure roster
um
the first year that i
swam
you are a hottie dude so this is your
second year of college first year
swimming freshman um this is at unlv but
they were letting you swim this year or
not um this is before i got um red
shirted oh my god so you had started the
season yeah i started season i got a
full ride i see cowinda too right now
that's my sister she was
kalila is a versatile swimmer who begins
her first season with the rebels she
will swim the butterfly and i am events
for the rebels this season
i'm a graduate butterfly kalila is a
2002 graduate of blair high school and
pasadena california finished first in
the hundred fly and second in the
hundred breast at the 1999 california
intergalactic federation championships
is the philippine national age group
record holder in the long course 200
breasts at two minutes two hours two
minutes two minutes i hope not two
minutes
i need to get another copywriter for
this this is with the
eulipsies you're a philippine national
age group record holder no i it's been
it's been broken after 16 years some
even more talented um filipina
broken god what do you do now what's
your name i think i'll kill myself
what's your next record going to be
[ __ ] dick
put those numbers up rudy do not
compete with her on that one
okay
is not worth it
yeah my sister was born in mexico were
you born in the philippines mm-hmm wow
my dad was just international amount of
mystery you never know where he was
going to be next you know
you guys are interesting like
similar looking and not at the same time
i don't think we look alike at all she's
hairless she has a delicate nose
and she has um she's six feet tall i'm
much hairier ethnic nose
big
features she has a very slender face
you both have like
apple cheese big big big cheeks did i
ever tell you guys about the night i was
at a frat party and
having so much fun just being crazy
being like wild
and this the whole night this guy who
was
a two um
was hitting on me like and i was so
funny and i was into it yeah we were
like vibing he was laughing at what i
was doing it was really fun he was a two
and um
then
we're sitting on the couch and some of
my friends from my i was in the
all-girls store somewhere the girls were
there with me and she the one girl's
drunk laughing she goes isn't esther so
funny she's doing all this and she's not
even drunk and the the two was like
you're not drunk
and i was like no and then he literally
didn't talk to me the rest of the night
of course because what shot does he have
with a sober girl
but it was like i was feeling it i was
like oh my god a guy is talking to me in
his head he's like there's no chance in
hell without beer goggles that she would
[ __ ] me oh he was insecure he was
insecure i thought it was he was just
like ew i thought he thought you were
the keg the whole night
wait speaking of keg why don't
do we have a beer bong here somewhere
did i not am i tripping it's there
annie this might trigger us a bit
where is it under annie under addie uh
under me we can do it with liquid death
or i can do it with a white claw
am i ready for a white cloth
gopi go right now this very second
carl's is under you
oh my god
if you peed on carlos that's behind the
paywall girls that goes on your own
i think i would pay your rent for three
months if you pee on carlos carlos i
have a proposition for you
ten thousand dollars that's a lot for
your only fans i get a 50 cut if i let
you
[ __ ] like my elbow and like the back of
my thigh
instead of a pillow
or
so i won't offer my um mouth at any of
the the major orifices but i can do like
a blindfolded like just i won't move my
hand but you can stick it in here i feel
a little insulted
no but it's just because i don't want to
be a participating yeah i don't want to
be like a a participating um you know we
got to keep it professional between you
and i right so it keeps it not sexual
between you and i i'm more of like an
ottoman or like something you can just
use in the room okay so so here i'm not
i don't have a lot of yeah what do you
think what about this one
pick some places out carlos
let's get some negotiating
between the butt cheeks no okay what
about i know that was asking for too
much
you mean my [ __ ]
feet
feet
you know i've never been look look look
oh yeah i forgot about that porn yeah we
can do that yeah is that would that turn
you on though foot job like
like a weird position
get the [ __ ]
get out
[Laughter]
of course i'll do this here i'll do this
first
oh my god he loves drinking she's so
quick to get drunk at work this is so
excited he's like i've been high at work
ready
cause loves to relapse
wait this is so dangerous
yes
carlos i'm worried
wow
wow ah he's happy breathing oh no
this is disgusting oh my god there's one
second left
yeah but you're supposed to move past
the burp work through it
and suffer later [ __ ] it you're fired
again we can't be promoting this kind of
behavior this is horrible college
what the kids quit before they're done
they're [ __ ]
well i did quit college
after a year same
oh my god look at these losers get out
of here i i stuck it out for eight full
years to get that underground
so you've never done a keg stand no
you've never done um a bong
both are like a beer bong no
do you smoke weed
yeah yeah
cute
she's so cute
so for your 21st birthday what do you um
what do you need from us like what are
your desires what can how can we help
you do you want to gamble in vegas you
want to go see shows what do you want to
do that sounds boring gambling it's so
fun oh my god there's this ding ding
ding ding ding
i just want to go to a pool party oh
well i've got to get my body ready for
that when you go to pools
i'm sorry when you go to parties are you
going to meet guys or just to have fun
you're just hoping there's a hot guy
there um both yeah yeah are you gonna
try to get like
effed up as they say maybe yeah who says
that on what
on just alcohol yeah okay what what
would be your pool drink like a frozen
thing i don't
just a tequila a tequila oh my god she's
classy do you take other drugs
um
just weed edibles we have rules oh what
are the rules i should follow the jewels
yeah you already know the rules what are
the rules jules
just
not any just sweet and edibles that's it
really no coke get onto coke coke's
boring what else
no
no pills probably no pills no pills
don't know what's in them yeah not worth
it
nothing
should we get her fentanyl test
um well she already knows she's not
going to touch any of them
yeah what about carlos again fired i
know what the [ __ ] those are so how many
episodes no i'm not getting attention at
all she just said she's only doing weed
oh well she's obviously going to try
other things no she's not there's not
obviously there okay i'm sorry oh my god
i'm playing devil's advocate you're not
gonna try did they put fentanyl in molly
oh i hope not god yeah because he is
molly is the only thing that you might
have and you know is it's a fun
party fun at like a pool but that's
where i would be so insecure and
probably ask for the fentanyl
test just in case did they cut [ __ ]
molly the only problem with molly is
that it's like it really you pay the
price in the hangover it's like you just
it takes all of your happiness and gives
it to you at once and then you have to
suffer through the rest right so it's
such a rush that it just depletes you
foreign
is that mdma
um yeah molly yeah well yeah i think
it's the same thing right is she allowed
mushrooms
oh mushrooms yes i want to try but we
try them together i've never done
shrooms oh my god
is that the next live
maybe that's the next live
yeah hell yeah dude
you want to do shrooms with us jewels oh
my god who's doing the epic dose
i don't really know i'm like i'm dead
i'm dead i'm bad
it would be hard to be around all this
oh god
yeah
oh really it'll be good be good okay so
i had these like
these memories of my mom getting hit on
so hard in front of us as kids like so
hard and my mom does not try like my mom
does not give a [ __ ] about beauty or
anything she is naturally beautiful but
she just doesn't she always cut her hair
short not that you're not hot if you
could but like not to be hot she always
like
wore like you know umbros and [ __ ] she
always was dressed like a little league
umpire
and
but our next-door neighbor leaned in we
were all in the minivan and he leaned in
and he he tongue-kissed my mom in front
of us once our neighbor and we were like
we're telling dad
and then there was another time where
they were
we had like we would go on camping trips
with this other family
i don't think my parents were saying
swingers but i think they were around a
lot of swingers but what i think a lot
of people are saying
i really don't think they are in denver
let's facetime them let's ask mom or dad
mom or dad i don't think my parents were
swingers but no but i swear to god
because there was this one this guy we
used to go camping with who like was
leaning in for kissing my mom and she
was like why did she receive the tongue
kisses no he should be like this she'd
be like this
and then but i remember i had a
boyfriend who i was like telling about
that and he was like well she doesn't
wear a bra i was like are you
slut-shaming my mom you're
victim-shaming her
your brother said that no no no that's
my boyfriend i had
let's see
she also
tripped on the subway ones
and when instead of helping her up the
guy showed her
his dick it's america that's actually
the funniest thing that's ever happened
yeah
so
hi mom
oh [ __ ] it's my headphones hold on [ __ ]
i'm blowing this
mom
mommy
oh they're on a walk say hi
we're on the podcast mom
okay we're on the podcast
okay so
i was telling them about when when our
neighbor leaned in and tongue kissed you
in the car
yeah and then i was remembering when we
went on that camping trip and that guy
leaned in to try to kiss you again
right yeah and then i said i don't think
my parents were swingers but they were
surrounded by a lot and then everyone
was like you're in denial your parents
were swingers so were you swingers
no
fortunately not yet
dad why was everyone trying to get your
girl
i mean he is she's not he's huh but he's
not a swinger oh boy he's hung but it
doesn't swing
now
i said um not a swing oh he's not a
swinger ooh i've seen dad's dick it's
not swinging that much but anyway
mom
are you
why did why did people always try to
kiss you
uh
i don't know they wanted to see if they
could kiss the queen mother
ew creepier
now my ex-boyfriend said that he thought
like you didn't wear bras and maybe that
was the thing how do you feel about that
uh
if they're really enticed by these
little things
they are sick people
all right mom so i don't think you were
a swinger either but these dirty dirty
[ __ ] did think you were
esther's still not sure i just
i i just i i never heard of people
hanging out with swingers knowingly
but not swinging what's the point of
that
they're friends oh
it's about friendship
it's for jennifer gardner
get old and they want to tongue kiss
people that are not their wives i think
yeah it's men
all right well smile for the camera mom
i can relate i want to tongue kiss
people that are not my wife all right
love you mama
bye daddy
so what do we think of what happens to
us as adults when we have
we grow up with naked moms or not naked
moms
i have like a very like standard level
of nudity i think it's like oh someone's
walking from
the bathroom
fast to their room they're naked she's
not doing this in front of the
mirror no that way your mama oh god
that's so funny she's not she's not
flexing her triceps in front of the
mirror
the brush shaking
oh it's so funny wait so um
because i think like
for instance like bobby if you look at
all of bobby's like baby pictures or his
pictures with his parents like his dad
was always just an underwear all the
time and i think that bobby takes on
that same look as an adult
and i think that
for me when i'm home
i'm always
partially naked
wouldn't you say jules yeah
i'm naked why wouldn't he the poo
it's cute on girls
sometimes
but most of the time i am winning the
pooling huh yeah it was just a t-shirt
and underwear oh
[Applause]
i'm just always naked yeah
i'm naked all the time too i make it all
the time i'm naked unless i'm on my
period are you esther
not at all so we've become our parents
so this is what we've learned i'm naked
all the time i do think i'll be naked on
my children yeah
bodies just be regular and not like be
insecure about it just it's just a body
but that's so funny that really is
my my kids are not going to like my tits
there's no left for a fact
well why we don't want them to like them
they don't need to like our bodies
that's true that's good thing i just
need to see
i didn't think of that anymore
i run listen i can't tell you how often
i'm just running by a window naked just
like oh well i'm never my clothes are
always open
my clothes always on the other side i'm
on this side but you're so you're never
naked i'm like fully dressed with
sneakers like i've seen you naked though
you've shown me your parts i'm sure i've
i'm not saying i've never been naked
early on
but maybe at home i'm never just like
chilling naked i'm fully dressed is it
because you're always cold i think it's
because i'm cold a lot i also braless is
not an option like i need things like in
place how do you sleep
with a big t-shirt and nothing else
okay nothing but a t-shirt yeah cause i
i need my boobs covered but not
held
do you ever put dave's cpap machine on
your tits
i don't think you suction those titties
i don't think i think they are too big
over the nipple
oh woe is you esther
[Laughter]
nothing has been too big for my or too
small for my tits in my life i think we
should all go around and say what we did
for our 21st birthday
starting with remember annie
we should all go around this is how it
goes
um
my 21st birthday i was sick
i was uh i was living in santa fe new
mexico i had a cold
um i had been drinking heavily since i
was 13. so i i had already quit drinking
and relapsed again
i did not give a [ __ ] about my 21st
birthday and i think it set me up for
having great birthdays for the rest of
my life because
every day has been my birthday my whole
life so i didn't really do anything too
special my my neighbors um
i was neighbors with this family
and i went with them and their little
kid i never heard that brace i was
neighbors with but they were actually
they were swingers
um
they never got me them but i went with
them and their family to like go look at
the choo choo trains with their kid that
wasn't his penis that wasn't like a
choo-choo train
i went we drove to chat um
chama this place in new mexico chama
we saw the trains we drove back
um i think i went out with one of my
friends and we just did some shots but
it was nothing really big
my parents called me
i was like
i was similar in that i had already been
drinking for so many years so it was not
exciting for me to turn 21 but i do
remember my sister's 21st birthday
because i woke up
to feeling cold and wet
on a bed next to her and it was because
she had peed
she was so
drunk from the night before that she had
wet the bed and it was like i'm
shivering why is it so cold
i look over at her and i'm like oh my
god and i think she brought like my
sister is a weird drunk in that she
finds she fixates on things at bars or
places where she's getting drunk and she
likes to take them home
oh
so she pulled she would pull like
budweiser signs from like bars
she brought him a bar stool like a full
[ __ ] bar stool are you i was that
type of drunk really collector yeah
and everyone hates it around you when
you're drunk you think this is going to
be awesome right and you're like yeah
i'm going to show up with like a yield
sign like you're like i'm going to have
all these stop sign we've she's plucked
out and actually stops now i had this i
went to the ye old rustic okay i had
moved my i was moving my yes here that's
here yes yes the yellow rustic i was
this i was an older drunk
that is where older drunks get yes
i was 24 or something my my ex-boyfriend
was marrying my friend i was driving her
out here to move in with him fun twisted
little ancestral santa fe
because it's a small town so i was with
all of them we were having we they lived
right next to the yield rustic so we
would walk to the yield rustic to drink
i got wasted i pulled a banner down off
of the thing dragged it back thinking
this is going to be awesome right
they're so much like we live here this
is our bar like
we like are here all this is we hang out
here every day ted
john
suzie we know them all like every person
here we know and i was like oh so then i
had to drag it back all hung over like
i'm sorry
but i'm glad to hear that because i've
always been like why did i think that
was so cool
you know it's uh my sister was a very
big backed swimmer so if she wanted it
she could get it off the wall so like
big things that were like like framed
and like bolted to the wall
if it was if we were like kuna you can't
get that let's just go let it you want
to boom boom and she would just like
pluck it off the leave hole did you ever
get chased yes
she just was like she's just like an
avid collector and then in your head you
think it's like you're like my room
looks cool why does why does it look
cool that there's like five traffic
cones
a stop sign
a two-for-one beer special banner
it was crazy like i remember i used to
always
you know i worked as like a go-go dancer
and a bar bartender and
you know a cocktail server and stuff and
i always like
even though i worked the job i still
loved when we would get like jaeger
shirts i was like jager shirts you know
and they just would come pass out okay
well that's cool now it would be cool
carlos did you have a 21st what did
carlos and pete what was your guy's 21st
birthday
i was sober so but i did a weird thing
when i moved here where i lied to
everyone that i was oh
so on my 20th birthday it was actually
my 21st birthday and i went to see 17
again starring zac efron with my uh
girlfriend at the group what a weird
psycho thing to lie about yeah what else
are you lying about the girlfriend
no she was real her name's hillary she
lives in portland now hillary yeah is
she dating women or men
her high school boyfriend okay oh she
went back yeah she went back she found
out i can't trust these guys they lie
about weird things like her age wait
it's possible to get your high school
boyfriend back it is my best friend
who's um
who my best friend is married to her the
guy she lost her virginity too
she will date brad pitt before you get
your ex boys
i still think it's totally possible i
don't think we're gonna get you out of
the [ __ ] here here's what you're just
only going family bowling you gotta be
out [ __ ]
you gotta catch us a celeb this is
getting annoying
if i can't even not cry at bowling with
my family what makes you think that i'm
ready to fight because you're with your
family that's why you're crying
i'm just not i don't know what to do i
don't know what to talk about i actually
i'm exhausted even thinking but i don't
want to [ __ ] talk to anybody for us
the men are going to come to her
yeah that's she's they're going to come
here well set it up how about that it's
up to you i will not turn down a date
that you set me up but it's gotta i have
a i have a criteria
good breath is number one okay damn it
i'm out
and for those reasons i'm out
um yeah good breath got to be a little
thick
i like chubs a little bit
um
that's about it good breath and chubby
what if he's married and he threatened
to sue us
what do you mean i'm just getting pumped
up
pete what was your 21st birthday
uh i got really wasted then my mom
showed up
your mom showed up because she was
concerned my brother was there uh
drinking he's younger than me but uh he
called my mom and then she showed up and
saw me passed out but then she was cool
your brother is a [ __ ] narc
[Laughter]
i woke up for the last time in my
college campus
and my parents
drove in packed up all my stuff moved me
home
it was like the saddest day ever because
everyone was so upset that i was
dropping out of school and then we got
home and they took me out to dinner to
one of my favorite vegetarian
restaurants blind faith cafe in evanston
and the
the owner was there and he gave me a
glass of wine and i took one sip and i i
spit it out but it was a very sad in his
face you [ __ ] [ __ ]
it was a sad 24 jules i feel like yours
should be somewhere in the middle of all
of our stories yeah you have to quit
something yeah you do have to quit like
she quit college and carlos quit the
beer bong
um college or carl's quit being honest
wait obviously
you
grew up in a country where drinking is
legal at a certain age so 21 is not as
exciting for you
18 most exciting probably more but when
what is the most [ __ ] up you've ever
been where you're like oh my god like
what did i just do
um like i was at a friend's
house because it was his birthday and
then we just drank a lot and then
i just passed out in the bathroom that's
it
around like people that you knew though
yeah oh so you weren't like afraid like
where am i who am i
i know honey god this is a very good
idea
i had a parent's weekend at my brother's
frat that
is infamous the tits
i don't know if my brother's still mad
at me about this but
i did flash the entire frat and it was
parents weekend so the grandmothers got
flashed the
parents got flagged your brother's frat
yeah
i was a 16 year old sister
nipple rings just wee proud of you
that's good i was so wasted i remember
max and i were taking shots to tequila
and um
[Music]
we were eating crackers and we were
blowing the crackers
spitting them at each other and i just
remember one getting caught in his eye
and on his eyelash and to this day my
maybe my favorite one of my favorite max
memories i'm just looking like a [ __ ]
idiot with that cracker on his eyelash
and when he got when we were in second
grade and he
opened up his fortune cooking you know
maybe there was one fortune maybe
there's two fortunes maybe there's three
and then he opened and there were no
fortunes
that might be the peak moment of my life
that wasn't the funniest things i've
ever seen
why won't he talk to me is your is your
older brother more like traumatized by
you like it seems like maybe you and max
were kind of like teaming up against
them no no no no timmy
no max is out max is barely in anymore
max is hanging on by a threat so max no
max is most traumatized by me yeah
timmy's fine timmy's still trying to get
a piece of the action
timmy's trying to get in on it
timmy calls into my show my spotify show
i want to talk about um
just one thing before we end because i
want jules's take on it so jules do you
know who nick cannon is
nick
i already am happy
he was at that that's crazy how was that
last night
do you want to explain who nick cannon
is it's really shocking
they can't i'm just going to explain
what i know of nick cannon from the from
the from the beginning from the
beginning his timeline i'm pretty sure
he was like uh had an mtv show all that
he was on all that he was not doing all
that he wasn't i don't think so
i just he was like a cool guy
you know oh my god this is already so
bad what was he famous for the mtv show
okay an mtv show he was pretty cool and
pretty cute actually like a good looking
cool cool guy yeah
fast forward he
marries mariah carey gets her pregnant
which is a big deal it's mariah carey
he's also a host of like not america's
got talent but one of you he's like got
goony game show hosting jobs like not
cool yeah very square almost like he has
a square persona like yeah clean kind of
but then like cut two you're hearing
these stories about how he's got all
these women pregnant
and then he goes on this podcast and
he's like
just holier than thou talking about how
80
of women's vaginas are unclean
and then also proceeds to talk about how
if women
don't respect and keep their vaginas
private then how can he respect them so
he's like telling women that they're
dirty and that they have to keep their
vaginas to themselves meanwhile he has
like eight baby mamas out there it's so
it's like what happened to you it's
interesting you said eight because in
1998 to 2000 he was in all that
he was he was in all that he was in
keenan and cal he was in the parker must
not have had many sketches because no he
wasn't in a bunch and then he had the he
had the nick cannon shows what you were
remembering him from that was in 2002.
he was on the chappelle show for
something i think he played himself so
this guy is a comedian out he was on
violin out yeah he's a comedian he
actually is the reason pete davidson
blew up
yeah he started bringing him on the road
and he like did like a pete uh nick
cannon presents for him well i know
nothing about nick cannon i was the
worst person and he was at the sushi
restaurant i was at last night and i
made the joke i was like did you have
enough uh baby seats did you have enough
children's seats
the waiter i don't know yeah
okay you were running around looking for
the high chairs well i hope you didn't
smell your
vagina like
what is up with that
what do you think about a guy who thinks
80 of women
vaginas are dirty jewels what's the
what's the vibe you're getting
he's gay
it does seem gay it does seem good
we're also sorry that society
led you down that path because i you
know in a way these people are victims
and but it doesn't apologize it doesn't
excuse their behavior whatever [ __ ] you
guys
i know you just yeah you think my vagina
is gross and smelly i'm sorry just stay
away from it yeah
we're for people that like our stinky
disgusting [ __ ] next month if i find
out i'm pregnant with nick cannon's baby
[Applause]
she went back on her word guys
she's going for gay guys we said we
wanted to get you a so we wanted you to
get us a celeb we didn't know it was
that one
on that note
jules are you traumatized no i like it
oh it was just like a normal
conversation without the koala yeah this
is how i talk at home jewels yeah yeah
you're right good you're right this is a
fun episode thanks for coming by jules
thank you so much for your college got
destroyed by covid we will make up for
it 911 happened my first week of college
if that helps that you've seen out see
how old i am
jules you know maybe our elect our next
live show will be around um your
birthday and maybe you can
you know partake with us mushrooms
and on that note we'll see you guys
next week see you next tuesday pictures
you guys vaginas are awesome we'll see
you next week just enjoy 100
only 20
although in this room only 20
that's so rude to say
[Music]
you